it's great to welcome to the program
today IDO Saad a man who is the founder
of saga saga is a stable coin which we
will be talking about but before we get
to that IDO so great to talk to you I
have so many things to discuss
starting with bitcoins volatility we see
the price of Bitcoin fluctuate and very
often this is attributed by some people
to either speculative actions by traders
or to the lack of what's called an
inherent value to Bitcoin how do you
interpret the price swings of a coin
like Bitcoin what does it mean what is
it caused by I I think it definitely
some of the price movements and the
volatility of Bitcoin is just a tribute
to to speculation but one must ask what
is the root cause for such a speculation
and I think that the root cause is a
fluctuating trust in in Bitcoin as a
currency it's nothing new I mean when
banks got these amazing machines new
technology that allows them to print
fields it didn't mean that anyone
trusted that those bill have told any
intrinsic value of their own and they
started by being a fully debtor to the
dollar in the Federal Reserve basements
right or the BIS basement for the rest
of the world so they hear that one can
introduce a new currency and before it
demonstrates the intrinsic value of
trust and and of network effect it could
be a stage stable relative to a basket
of prices or whatever else I think is is
rather naive i think that what we're
seeing is inherent to the Bitcoin bubble
of being non tethered to anything else
and abruptly trying to amass trust and
this translate into into volatility
translates definitely into many
speculation opportunities and and such
opportunities are widely used so when
people talk about the different uses of
for example
Bitcoin etherium you know the most the
most widely transacted crypto currencies
sometimes we hear it's a good
transactional currency and people debate
that and then they talk about
transaction times and transaction speeds
etc another common use that is cited is
well it's a store of value it's a place
to store value and of course when you
see the volatility that makes some
people say well sure you can store value
but it's a radically it's a it's a
quickly changing amount of value that
you are able to store as you see it our
Bitcoin and aetherium tools to store
value or our is that not really a proper
usage for them it might become a store
value I don't think it will become a
medium of exchange and as such I don't
think that we will see be going behave
as money or be adopted by the market as
money but it is storing value
effectively I think that is doing so
with a very high level of liquidity over
volatility sorry which would not allow
us to treat it as a store of value that
is equivalent to a currency right one
would would assume that buying startup
stocks in in their seed round these
storing value as well but it is an
extremely dangerous store value and in
this extremely volatile one I think that
when we refer to store a value from a
monetary perspective is one of those
three functions of the currency I don't
think that bitcoin is there yet it might
become one I don't see how because you
speak to become a fully transactional
currency so before we get into what saga
is doing what do you think is primarily
holding down adoption rates from the
general public to use cryptocurrency
that other alternatives do not bring and
I think that each cryptocurrency needs
to be tested or examine recently the
targeted sets the target problem accepts
you so and I think that we're not
solving well enough the problems that we
as an industry were set to solve if we
add to that a user experience that is
extremely cumbersome and problematic
regulatory lack of clarity that prevents
major player institutional players from
entering the game as well as well as
preventing several projects from from
actually seeing the light of day then we
are seeing that the what I believe is
the main challenge of the industry I
don't think it is insurmountable that's
why we're all here I guess yeah so let's
let's now talk about saga I've read that
saga works in tandem with the global
economy we talked about it as a stable
coin if people haven't heard of the
project how do you introduce them to it
what is the project what's its goal is
actually not stable core and it is not
designed to be stable it is designed
with stabilizing mechanism so that on
its way to have an intrinsic value this
independent intrinsic value that we
discussed in regard to Bitcoin the the
way the way there is less volatile and
and less bumpy what side is designed the
problem that some is design to soul is
of issuing a complimentary global
currency of momentum in the sense that
we are not down the debate of whether
fiat currencies are good or bad for us
it is much simpler to state the fiat
currencies are national and as such they
were designed to meet the needs of
national economies but we are
seeing an ever-growing scope of a global
economy where the unit of account the
prices are not determined by any single
state or any single market system when
there is a new scope of an economy it
requires a new currency to give an
example and not fair leaving the
completely abstract if you're a British
citizen and in the past three years
you've seen your currency to lose about
25 percent of its value because of
directive decisions when you actually
purchase within Britain you're fine
you're protected because the British
economy we ask you the same decisions as
the British currency as the British
monetary policy we ask you but when you
go in buy on Amazon the prices there
have way less consideration to our
Majesty's Parliament's decisions and and
here when when you are British but
acting as this global citizen exposed to
global prices you remain vulnerable this
is exactly the issue that saga aims to
resolve to address and not only for
private customers this is a
thousand-fold
approver for global corporations that
need to manage hedging floors and FX
floors because they are serving
customers from hundreds of countries and
suppliers from hundreds of thousands of
countries I I think that in the last few
months it is becoming evidently clearer
that the world needs a global currency
and and we're very happy to see that the
debate is shifting from whether the
world needs one - how should it be done
and I just end up this point with with
the reference in Christine Lagarde's
last statement at the head of the new
head of the ECB saying it is evident
that global currencies and global
payment system are manifested Lee needed
and if we don't address these needs and
the industry address it so is there some
way in which what Saga does emulates
what governments do but on a different
scale
in some sense yes so we are very much
inspired by central banking tools
instruments that are meant to tame the
changes to tame the growth and
dependable ability with it what we've
done is that we implemented saga is a
variable fractional reserve which means
that certainly is a fully elastic supply
of money when one buys it from the
contracts Ari is created when one sells
it back to the contract which is an
imperial contract it is it is burned and
so the number of sagas in the world is
what the our local uses as a vote of
confidence in saga when there is a low
amount of saga in the world it means
that no one trust us yet and this is
where the reserve ratio is 100 percent
we are 100 percent pegged to the SDR
which is the IMF basket of currencies
it's a basket of 5 currencies Dollar
Euro Pound yen in remand Beach so that
we have global exposure but as the
economy grows and there are more suckers
that are being created by the market we
are starting to lower our dependency on
the reserve in favour of an intrinsic
appreciation of the Sun a token as the
market appreciates and you know how is
the decision made about the degree to
which you are pegged and how you reduce
it over time what metric is used to
decide that this number is being
determined by the market there is no
intervention needed to lower or to or to
increase the reserve rate because Trust
can not only be gained it can be lost as
well so if the economy shrinks these
more suckers are being burned by the
market than being bought by the market
then the reserve ratio goes back after
price goes back down and and so by
design we're not stable the price of
saga will change but it will change very
very very slowly how do you ensure that
there is liquidity in the SG a token at
all times when one by saga all the
proceeds of buying saga are deposited
Reserve when one cell saga the proceeds
from the same reserve are being
liquidated in favor of buying back of
the contract buying back the saga and
and so the liquidity is being managed by
the market operation itself it's a
self-regulating model of supply of money
when we launched sagar a week ago there
was zero money in reserve and zero saga
out there
the reserve is being populated by the
creation of sorry itself
how does saga make money that's a great
question so first of all as an operation
starter doesn't make money
it is built as a company limited by
guarantee in the UK because that's the
only structure that we had available but
we adopted a constitution and articles
that prevent any distribution of
dividend that prevent any source of
profit in saga other than the
maintenance of the protocol this being
said when the vertex and light spins and
member of the world invested in saga
because we did not do Nico we went to
accredited investors - if you want old
world VC's not so old but but in crypto
turrets in crypto age and they didn't
invest in us in an impact investment
there okay they're in it to profit from
the success of saga the way we did it is
that we issued a second token whole saga
Genesis which is convertible to saga the
ratio that changes as the economy grows
so they all sat at Genesis SG n
currently they send s GM to the convert
they will get 0 saga because the economy
is very small as the economy new will
become bigger they will get more and
more sagas / s GM but we stopped them
to 15 times meaning 1 is GN at maximum
when sagas economy would be worth 3
trillion dollars one as GN would be only
worth 15 sagas because at no time we
want the investors to perform the
economy the control of the economy is is
left only to the car
see holders to the participants of the
project so it seems that in a lot of the
different systems you've put in place
there's a priority placed on not
allowing any small group of people to
call too much power so in the sense that
you have an algorithm through which you
will move away from that currency basket
in terms of dictating the trajectory of
of the currency you've put a limit on
the amount that individual investors
could put in is that a priority to set
up a system that doesn't depend on you
personally being there but that will
sort of last beyond the individuals is a
priority for us to every system
represent the holders of the currency we
we may have many criticisms in regards
to central banks but central banks are
eventually being appointed by
governments that are being elected by
citizens of nation-states and I think
that we need to replicate this
accountability even if we replicate it
in completely different measures we need
to replicate this accountability
eventually I apparently leading saga but
that would be up to elections of the
currency order in eight year year from
now because some is not mine I I think
that if we want to provide services that
are semi civic services right then we
need to adopt Civic standards of non
ownership of a no centralized group of
people that can take decisions without
being accountable to to the tokens
economy absolutely fascinating project
we've been speaking with sagas founder
IDO Simon you can find out more about
the project using the links down in the
video description
IDO such a pleasure talking to you today